[Musique]
pas trop exact on vous demande
d'attendre d'attendre mais vous avez
aucune
aucune information quand tu as une
reprise enfin c'est ça reste très floue
tout ça ce n'est qu'à 21h30 que
l'ensemble des passagers a pu être
évacué il y a toutes des campagnes de
communication qui nous dit mais faut que
vous prenez les transports en commun il
faut lutter pour l'écologie mais quand
vous voyez genre de choses vous n'avez
absolument pas envie aller dans les
autres pays d'Europe allez en Allemagne
aller dans les pays de l'Est aller en
Italie vous verrez que les transports en
commun sont impeccables les trains sont
climatisés les trains régionaux sont
climatisés et j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi nous on était pas capable de
mettre la clim de mettre une ordination
dans tous les transmets on va vers le
chauffage climatique le monde vient de
connaître son début de mois de juin le
plus chaud jamais enregistré c'est ce
qu'annonce le service européen
Copernicus le plus chaud et de loin
bonsoir Sébastien Thomas alors on s'en
doutait un petit peu pour la France mais
le phénomène est donc planétaire c'est
un constat sans ambiguïté on va
décrypter ensemble ces courbes avec les
températures moyennes de la planète
mesurée donc par l'Institut Européen
Copernicus capable de remonter jusqu'en
1940 on voit qu'il fait plus chaud l'été
il y a urgence la pandémie n'était rien
à côté du dérèglement climatique on ne
peut même pas imaginer ce qui va arriver
les enfants et les personnes âgées
mourront en premier
nous souffrirons aussi de famines de
pénuridaux et de conflits armés
ça ne va faire qu'empirer avec le temps
qu'attendons-nous maintenant on va
ajouter les années les plus récentes que
la planète a connu regardez elles sont
toutes au-dessus de cette moyenne et
regardez si on ajoute juin 2023 c'est
encore pire pour l'instant c'est le plus
chaud des mois de juin jamais observés
alors qu'il n'est pas terminé à ne se
fixer la traduction du réchauffement
climatique causée par les activités
humaines un orage s'approche
dangereusement de l'embarcation
quand il
pleut il y a une commande
vous pouvez défendre ce genre d'action
mais on ne fait rien non en fait
quoi comment vous sauver le monde
merci Nicolas
non mais c'est vrai Nicolas non mais
c'est vrai c'est une connerie
depuis des années tu as fait remboursé
le monde en quoi mais moi j'agis
là ça va
alors tu respires tu ne t'énerves plus
ok voilà c'est dimanche oui
faire la vaisselle tu fais quoi
par exemple voilà j'agis concrètement
pour la planète
un vélociraptor dans les allées du
Parlement colombien à Bogota bon en
réalité c'est un dinosaure inoffensif
évidemment je vous présente Francky
c'est son petit nom Franck il dit non
c'est une opération de communication de
la part de l'ONU et si tu une opération
de communication qui a débuté en 2021 on
est dans l'État du Nevada et tous les
petits points noirs que vous voyez sur
ces images et bien ce sont des insectes
plus particulièrement des criquets en
fait l'état fait face à une véritable
invasion d'insectes on parle de millions
de criquets ils sont partout vous le
voyez sur les murs sur le sol dans les
arbres dans les jardins ouais ça fait ça
fait pas très envie des images comme
celle-ci on en trouve partout sur les
réseaux sociaux
oh mon Dieu on les entend craquer sous
les roues inoffensif pour l'homme c'est
criquets mormons arrivés depuis
maintenant trois jours ça tac au terre
cultivé et au jardin on reste à
l'intérieur une sorte plus dehors il
tombe du plafond et oui ils sont
horribles
il tombe du plafond ils sont vraiment
dégoûtants
bon alors c'est pas un phénomène inédit
cette invasion de criquets dans l'État
du Nevada en fait au moment du printemps
tous les quatre à six ans les criquets
font une grande migration vers l'ouest
du pays mais avec le réchauffement
climatique et bien le phénomène
d'invasion tant à se renforcer justement
en 2021 ils avaient déjà fait une petite
vidéo avec Franky ou ce dinosaure
s'adressait aux dirigeants du monde
entier mais ils disent quoi ce
dinosaures il disait en termes
d'extinction moi je m'y connais hein
j'ai pas eu le choix il y a un astéroïde
qui est tombé mon espèce a disparu c'est
lui qui vient alerter sur le et voilà
exactement et c'est ça en fait il est
vous vous avez une menace
climatique qui menace votre espèce et
vous pouvez agir des chercheurs de
l'Institut universitaire européen de la
mère à Brest ont analysé l'impact du son
émis par les eaux et lianes sur les
coquillages sur les coquilles
Saint-Jacques donc et leurs travaux ont
montré que les coquilles pouvaient
entendre le bruit d'abord 220 décibels à
la source que ça ne les tue pas c'est
pas létal mais ça les stress les
coquilles Saint-Jacques et ça réduit
sensiblement l'organe génital du
coquillage qui se situe vaguement dans
le corail
[Musique]
étincelle oui d'un mot d'amour pour mon
chat allumer le feu c'est vous qui allez
nous raconter le parcours de Johnny
depuis le square de la Trinité jusqu'au
plus grande scène de France en passant
par les routes mythiques du Midwest
américain qu'est-ce que ça a suscité
chez vous de raconter l'histoire de
cette amie que vous avez croisé un jour
et que vous avez aimé instantanément
demain Télématin c'est à 6h30 à 13h
Nathan Nathan elle dort bonne soirée
[Musique]